Then let's start by avoiding friendship Hioka Aiko's Reitesenger chapyo car
Unfortunately, the presentation is a tension rap battle I'm trying Daikyo Jatz with cheese and lime You
seem to be surprisingly familiar with the three colors of backing  Power greed emotion
I'll always have it with a smile
Scythe innovation Trying to do fractional baths
I'm noisy That's my style
[music]
tehen
2 I'm a noggle, you're a trap,
you're angry I'm a
mool  Give me a law
I don't know the superiority or inferiority of rap I guess that's why maids are there I
'm sorry I couldn't hear the sound of the waterfall because it was too loud
Well then mc Mizushima and mc Kimura's efforts were in
vain No, not in vain  There was meaning in knowing it was useless When I
got home, I sang a love song to the maids in the same environment to see if Jun would come
.
The opinion that I don't understand was helpful, too.
I
wanted to be cute because I felt like I was on my way home from school, so I asked for help with gaining weight
.